good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everyone's
doing well hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing well how are you doing I'm clearly
amazing it seems not well I'm I'm
actually incredible like I feel like
this burden that's been on my shoulder
for like a month has been lifted you
know the first show of my special
recording last night under my belt it
went in crayab and like there's really
no feeling quite like that I can't
explain like when you have like a hurdle
you've been looking no well not even
looking forward to but like a hurdle on
the horizon yes a hurdle on the horizon
the name of today's episode and the
hurdle is behind me and Bryce is in
studio oh my God if you're watching on
YouTube Bryce is moseying around he's so
excited to come to work today he had a
pep in his step there's nothing he loves
more than walking in these city streets
with his mom and just like everybody's
always remarking on the beauty of Bryce
like that's actually not an exaggeration
no by the way I get like not to you know
like I do get the same thing with Theo
not to be like so like no that happens
to me too but like it does I believe you
because it is just the breed they are
quite remarkable remarkable and he's
feeling himself he's feeling New York
City he's feeling his day and he's
excited to be at work which is new for
him I'm so happy Bryce is here it's
really added like a spirit to the energy
of the studio that we haven't seen since
you left town wow do you hear that Bryce
you're a star you're mommy star it's
really amazing to have him here it's
really amazing to have you here actually
I wanted to like make like a little
speech if I could oh my God yeah you
want to make a toast well yeah here
I am a sustainable girly using our toast
tumbler available at toastmerch.com and
Jackie hates the planet I am using a
recycled lid it's true
yes this is this is Lizzy's lid and I
used to use after her because I too am
sustainable yes plastic straw Queen love
that for you classic straws compared to
Plastics in general are like point zero
one percent of the problem so I'm not
giving them up I drink from every
morning at home I drink from my reusable
cup with a plastic straw just to drive
home the point I I hear that but let me
get to the toast but yeah because you
drank and I didn't pick your cup up
so first of all last night really was
incredible like it was um
it was like a moment for me like an
emotional but like it was really special
like I did
like I did amazing and it was such a
good show and it was literally the best
audience like ever and Jax Margo and Ben
were in the audience and like really
having you there was so
it was so special and I know like it was
a journey for you to get here like you
brought Harry and Harry as a cold and
like it's like a whole thing I
appreciate it so much like I was really
thinking last night how like it would
not have been the same if you weren't
there and I trust your opinion like so
deeply that like I I couldn't I was like
should I have one button open or two
like I couldn't make a decision without
you and I was really glad that you were
there and I know you're coming in
tonight and I just really wanted to say
thank you like it means a lot to me and
it was just a great night and it
wouldn't have been the same without you
honestly that's so sweet I see cheers
pure water in your eyes no because
Harry's eyes because it really was such
a great night it was I'm so excited to
do it again knowing that I have an
amazing show under my belt like I like
today will just be fun for you it's the
last show ever ever this is the one that
like all the friends are coming to and
then we can go out to dinner later so
it's just like you the pressure is off
the pressure's on if you stink tonight
which you won't because when you're more
relaxed you do better
even if you had to just use what you
recorded last night and not be able to
edit anything like it would be an
amazing special I'm like really glad I I
did too because I think it relieves a
lot of the pressure of like hitting
every joke but if last night is the only
one I use for the special I'll probably
end up cutting both but if it's only one
I use I will be so thrilled it would be
enough for us it really would be enough
so now I'm like feeling really relaxed I
loved the way I looked which is really
half the battle like when you feel
insecure like you do badly it's just I
don't make the rules it's just math
um it was just incredible night like it
really was it was just it was a night
I'll really remember forever it's up
there with msgt Wow and the show was at
seven so I literally got home and I'm
showered by 9 30 and I watched three
episodes of Yellowstone and like the joy
I actually cannot put into words of like
having this Milestone behind me getting
into bed with like a fresh vagine
heating pad on Theo next to me me and
Ben watching Yellowstone
they're just genuinely no words for
that's what heaven is like for real like
I imagine Heaven is a big bed with your
loved ones platonically unless you know
you know
um and just feeling at peace with a
heating pad I love that I don't have a
heating pad on this journey and um price
is like Mom I literally needed one thing
and you forgot to pack it you bought you
packed 100 things for that yeah no he
Bryce was suffering he was like
suffering he was suffering except he got
to sleep with his mommy and he's a happy
boy but yes I got to be in bed pretty
early and even though it was like a sick
night of sleep with the baby
um we actually got decent sleep
considering we had enough time to
conquer it you know I like kind of love
doing a show at seven o'clock there's
also nothing better than doing a show
and sleeping in your own bed it doesn't
happen a lot it happens like when I do
like Delaware Jersey obviously New York
Atlanta because they have an 11 p.m
flight from Hartfield Jackson
where I was actually an amusement park
where I was airport I was literally
mowed down there I know by a dumpster
it's one of the most traumatizing things
that ever happened to me I couldn't
believe it like it sounds like a
metaphor like you like try an ugly
person but no like what did you just
dumpster no I was actually mowed down by
a dumpster on Wheels you know it sounds
like you a metaphor like I was mowed
down by a dumpster oh like it was a
human but no it was an actual dumpster
and it was this big you know those huge
ones they like rolled through the
airport and they put all the big
garbages in it yeah I'm literally
standing waiting at the gate and I'm
literally run over it was one of the top
craziest things that ever happened to me
in my life yeah it was more so it really
hurt but it was also the shock of like a
huge metal thing like barreling into I'm
sure it was crazy I'm sure
um so and I'm just so excited to do it
again tonight like I feel really I feel
great I feel really great I just feel
great I'm so glad for you how do you
feel I feel good I'm I'm I've got a lot
going on and this week isn't like
turning out the way that I thought
because so I'm just like in cyclandia
but still happy to be here happy to
support and once tonight's over like I
don't care if I'm sick for whatever else
I have this week like I'm gonna be
coming over Harry won't be sick for much
longer because I'm I'll inhale all this
not out of him like great I don't even
care great can you get sick from a kid
like yeah yes but like just as easily as
like another adult no I I guess not
because like the kids have weaker immune
systems so what might make them sick
wouldn't make an adult sick right but
usually the other time that he was sick
like I got it a few days after him so
that might still happen but that
actually works because it gives me
enough time to take care of him right
and then deal with myself nature is
amazing they've thought of everything
they've thought of everything you look
stunning today thank you so much I
really didn't like put my well it's day
two of the spray tan which is like it's
the best day it settled and I didn't
have my spray tan foundation with me
because you kind of sprung the spray tan
on me in a positive way you surprised
and delighted me so I didn't have like
my other shape so yesterday it was like
my makeup was not highlighting my spray
tan but today it all works and so no you
really look stunning thank you so much
I'm surprised you're not more tan living
in Florida like do you ever spend time
outside no I've never laid out
outside and you have such a great
outdoor space in your house yeah it just
hasn't happened for me yet but maybe
maybe one day I don't know but I now
that I live in Florida like I do like
tan locks every other day so show those
legs yeah because so is that something
like that's been a challenge for you
like having to show your legs more
frequently that's something I struggle
with during the summer time no not
really
because also if I don't want to show
them I just wear leggings like people do
dress like I could wear this I do wear
this you wear a turtleneck in Florida
it's not this one's not really a
turtleneck because it's a loose you know
it's not like a cashmere turtleneck like
no but it's a full Turtle it's just a
high neck I think no it's just a
turtleneck that goes literally up to
your tooth no but there's like a slit
here for breathability and it's you see
it's loose I could always fold it over
as well if I didn't get makeup on it
well then it wouldn't be a turtleneck
but it is now
okay it's just like sure come for me
after the glowing things are you sure no
you know me what the grunge giveth the
grunge taketh away so true so true
um so it's just another fabulous episode
full and a fabulous week here at the
toast I loved yesterday's episode I
actually watched it in full when I got
home because I had like like an hour
between when I had to get to the venue
and the episode I was like what should I
do and I watched it we were being so
funny we were funny we are funny it's so
true it's let's talk more about that
anytime I say so true like to even
though that's like a normal thing to say
what do you think of fabletics well no
what was that oh no that's it fun fabfit
fun the first time when we were doing
the breath the first time we tried to
like record an ad no I think of Kourtney
Kardashian like in that variety
interview when Kim said get your [ __ ]
so Trail yeah so true no that fabfit fun
which we haven't told the story in a
while yeah no but that one was so
expensive okay so no was it expensive it
was expensive so the first time we ever
ever sold an ad on our show when we were
called the morning breath we had to like
pre-record in the studio and it was like
the first time we'd ever read ad copy
and so Jackie and I are in the studio
with Olivia and the copy was dumb like
it was Dumb and like we were reading it
like so many times and we were we were
like being actress you know like doing
effervescent and we were also just like
like laughing at each other oh my God
like sales women we had to do it 500
times because we couldn't stop laughing
and then like we started to just like
put weird intonations on certain words
so we were talking about how at the Fab
is fabfitfun still in business
I think I haven't heard of them in a
while I haven't either but I think that
they are but they were like an
influencer because it's just like the
algorithm left them behind so basically
the concept is like you get this box
every season full of full sized items
like Beauty Wellness lifestyle and
they're doing 12 days of fat fit fun
okay and you can keep this isn't an ad
you can carry your perfect winter box
whatever so the point of the copy was
like you're gonna get these items that
are so expensive but you're only gonna
pay 49.99 for the box and we said it
over and over again by the end it's
gotten longer and longer so expensive
and ever since then I haven't been able
to say the word so normally that's so
true right but no now I'm thinking a
variety interview only when I say so
true yeah that's like a
that's like such a funny um like that's
not what no because that moment went
viral not for what Courtney said like no
but Courtney's just being there so true
anytime you say something and I say it's
so true I feel like Courtney that's a
good one thing I didn't think of that
um well we've got a great show we
actually have great stories some tragic
news oh my gosh
you know so tragic happen when you were
on stage last night sometimes I'll be on
stage like something crazy will happen I
remember
um when Carly Kloss and
what's the less famous I can never
remember when they got married like it
was a surprise and I got off stage our
members in Cleveland and I was like
where they got married like sometimes
crazy [ __ ] happens when I'm on stage I'm
only on stage for like an hour hour and
a half
it's like the world but it's like prime
time it's like you know seven o'clock
news yeah no that's true that's so true
it's so true
title of today's episode what did I say
the other one was
something that always happened hurdle on
the horizon so true that they're sorry
I love that
um so yeah we've got a great show
nothing else to really talk about
because everyone in New York is talking
about my show
um
it is it's so true it is being in New
York like this city is just like so
darling this week oh you're not here on
Sunday I don't know if you know this and
I usually hate when like the city
lawmakers do this like close down
streets for no reason but the next two
Sundays in December they are closing
down Fifth Avenue and there's like a
bunch of Christmas displays all day it's
actually a really cute concept even
though it's gonna like make mayhem in
traffic for everyone
um so you're not here on a Sunday but
how much of Fifth Avenue like a decent
chunk like the good chunk where all the
stores are where the Christmas displayed
by the plaza and so can you walk in the
middle of the street oh so it's like a
street bear of Christmas things right
and there's like hot treats and things
that's really cute I know Harry would
love it you should go maybe yeah take
Theo Feast for the senses a feast it
actually is like torture like I'm gonna
make him walk past like these lights and
bushes and snacks that he can eat I'm
like get out of here much too good for
Theo
um so I wish you could have seen that
and I actually think that's a cute idea
it is cute I hope that the city dwellers
like it yeah the Dwellers
um I guess without further Ado I guess
we could get into do you want are you
gonna recap Yellowstone a little bit
more at the end of the show sure I do
have some thoughts I mean I'm sure I'll
weave it into whatever we talk about
today I'll make Kirstie Alley Kirsty
alley about Yellowstone because she
should have been on the show and that's
the only thing that's missing from the
show 100
without further Ado where is Brew he's
with his mommy at work being an amazing
Angel and it's such a joy to have such a
joyous love here with Mommy here are the
past five stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you an
episode
I don't like them
today's episode is brought to you by
Babble
this holiday season if you're looking
for a unique gift that inspires
curiosity travel and culture give the
gift of Babel the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you'll finally be able
to discover the wonder that comes with
learning a new language which is such a
great thing to tackle like your license
like there are certain things as an
adult like you feel really accomplished
once you tackle I'm trying to get Jackie
to stand up like it's one of those
things that like you will feel so
accomplished because it's really so
difficult
um and babbles makes it so easy should I
do stand up or should I learn from
example and learn a new language I mean
I think if I'm a betting woman you'll
probably end up doing Bible because I
know you actually want to yeah um so
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks so
this is what I did like if you're
traveling out of the country and you
want to learn the basics Babel is a
great thing to do just a few weeks
before your trip it'll really help you
brush up on just like the the basics
yeah to get around and also to help you
get excited like a little pregame for
your trip just sitting in your apartment
wearing a beret learning French yeah
drinking red wine other language apps
use AI for their lesson plans but Babel
was created by over 150 language experts
you can choose from French German
Italian Spanish they have over 14
languages right now you can also get up
to 55 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com TMT that's Babel
babel.com
TMT for up to 55 off your subscription
Babble language for life love Babble you
guys also I never thought but it makes
such an amazing gift especially if you
are planning to take a trip with someone
like say you have something planned for
later in the year like that's a great
Christmas gift for them uh
toast approved gifts today's episode is
also brought to you by liquid IV the one
thing that might be missing from your
daily routine hydration I know it's
missing for mine liquid IV fuels your
everyday well-being by helping you stay
hydrated in just one stick of liquid IV
you get five essential vitamins and
you're hydrating two times faster than
water alone I'm all about time
management I really am so if I'm gonna
drink this bottle of water would I
rather drink this bottle of water or
drink this bottle of water that has
liquid IV and five essential vitamins
and three times the hydration the latter
the latter I think so too ladder IV
um okay so if you need to hydrate better
whether you're just not drinking enough
water you're hungover if you've been
working out a lot liquid IV is a great
option because one stick into 16 ounces
of water hydrates you two times faster
and more efficiently than water alone
halso has a ton of vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12
vitamin C it has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients it's non-GMO it's free from
gluten dairy and soy and they're on a
mission to change the world so to date
liquid idea is donated over 25 million
servings in over 50 countries around the
world so you know that your purchase is
in good hands grab your liquid IV in
bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20 off
when you shop better hydration at liquid
iv.com use code toast to check out this
is something you just want to stock up
on and always have in your house because
like whether you're if you're getting
like headaches from being that's how I
get most of my headaches from being
dehydrated or you're hungover you don't
have to like go out and get it order it
just have it stocked up the pack it
comes with a lot of sticks so you'll be
set for for a good amount of time so 20
off anything when you use co-host at
liquid iv.com liquid iv.com promo code
t-o-a-s-t what does that spell toast
when do we want it now what are we gonna
drink look at Ivy
how are we gonna speak with the language
we learned on Babel
okay our first story Switching gears in
a major way Kirsty alley has died at the
age of 71 after a short battle with
cancer the famed actress Kirsty alley
has passed away her children announced
the news Monday evening with a statement
shared via Kirsty social media accounts
saying quote she passed away after a
battle with cancer only recently
discovered she was surrounded by her
closest family and fought with great
strength leaving us with a certainty of
her never-ending Joy of living and
whatever Adventures lie ahead we are
grateful to the incredible team of
doctors and nurses at the mofit Cancer
Center for their care you know I haven't
thought of Kirsty alley probably in 10
years like she hasn't crossed my mind
but I was so
sad when I heard this because and I
guess I never really even really like
sat down and thought at a glance like
how much of an impact her work really
had on me yeah at a young age like her
my like literally one of my favorite
movies from childhood that really just
reminds me of like our family is look
who's talking with with Adele dazeem and
it's lit and I think there's a sequel
too it's such a good movie and you
reminded me last night she's the iconic
camp counselor and it takes two with
Mary Kate and Ashley original counselor
and there's just like so much of her
work I think I think she was in cheers
and that's what most people I didn't
watch cheers but her work like really um
was like a part of my childhood and I
feel like I felt so I felt like such an
overwhelming sadness which I felt
surprised by because I haven't even
really thought about her like in years
and then she did Weight Watchers which
was
iconic yeah and I don't know I just feel
really sad because obviously 70 is Young
and she had just discovered she had
cancer and it's just like a really sad
story it's a really sad story she was
also in Veronica's Closet which is
um something that she had a lot of Fame
for in her early career which was before
our time more recently she was in Scream
Queens you remember that season she made
it all the way through scream Queens I
know that's crazy because like everyone
loves it it's so good I should just
watch it because I'll it's like
Yellowstone and Downton Abbey in Reading
yeah but then you'll just be sad that
there's no more but then it's coming
back yeah no that's the thing about
really good shows that like never took
off you don't even want to recommend
them like recommending the society to
someone like getting them so invested
like you're gonna ruin their life 100
but you could get them to your side
right of caring yeah also she was in
like a lot of iconic movies like Drop
Dead Gorgeous have you seen that one no
the about the pageant I think that you
have about the pageant with um
Kirsten Dunst no tears
Kirsten and Kirsten it's like a small
town pageant and there's like murder oh
no murder mystery no I never heard of
that looks really good my Kirsty alley
like references are really it takes two
and look who's talking I loved the movie
look who's talking like I we we had it
on VCR for sure and we watched like a
million times yeah her IMDb like never
ends yeah no that's um it's really sad
and oh and by the way you know what her
son's name is Rip
I saw that
because he posted on social media and so
a lot of people she was ahead of her
time a lot of people were looking at it
for his tribute and his name is Rip
which I was literally talking about
yesterday I'm gonna name my son rep even
though it says that her son's name is
William true Stevenson and her
daughter's name is Lily price Stevenson
that's so interesting okay so maybe
William named his son rip someone is
named rep let me search just someone no
someone posted it in toast after dark
like are you sure it's not rip Kirsty
alley
oh Jackie oh my God how dumb do you
think I am really dumb apparently I just
searched rip okay here
her daughter
named her son so Kirstie Alley's
grandson how old is the grandson because
the baby so it's from Yellowstone I mean
it could be but the name did exist
before and to update what I said from
yesterday rip is usually short for
Ripley
Believe It or Not
Ripley yeah it is there's just like I
don't give a rip
you know like I absolutely name your sun
rip because I've been really calling him
I'd be like rip
no you know I always talk about time for
rip I want your dinner now you call it
your other son Theo dinner yeah no I
just want to say I feel like we get on
this show a lot and like really
um talk about how many benefits are and
how proud We Are to be Jewish but
there's one thing like that there's a
little bit of a drawback and it's like
you're limited in your name options
because like I can't be out here naming
you know Walker rip you know hey walk or
software yeah like you have to really
like do like a Jewish name whether it's
like biblical or familial like that's
why when P like you'll know someone's
Jewish when you hear their name you're
never going to meet obviously like a Jew
named Christian or like right no but
there are a lot of these like newfangled
names like they just don't the modern
names like McKinley it's like McKinley
Goldberg like you're never gonna hear
that like William McKinley it's kind of
classic it's true but Willie McKinley
was not Jewish no but it's not a
newfangled name technically okay but you
know you know the names from the
chalkboard Hawthorne yeah like of course
yeah craxton
like we can't use those names as Jews no
there's also like one other thing that I
don't like about being Jewish
um actually the rapid anti-Semitism no I
know but I actually love Jewish wedding
ceremonies like I think all the the
things that you do are like so special
but you don't say I do
you know like we're just raised watching
movies it's like I do I do you actually
don't say I do you could work it into
your ceremony if you want to it depends
but like the ones we had like you really
can't well I mean there's a lot of room
for customization yeah customize but I'm
also very traditional like I wanted to
do I feel like I said it I never thought
about if I did you didn't actually like
you know am I even married no why
but actually I forgot to wear my ring
today me too oh my God Scoops rip hey
um no but uh me and Ben actually we did
vows you don't really do vows in Jewish
um so we did customize it a little bit
and the final line actually My Vow
people were cracking up do you remember
uh
no I said to Ben you know I've always
dreamed of saying I do to someone
exactly like you until I learned that
saying I do is not a thing that Jewish
people say so even though nobody asked I
do when I tell you Rabbi luckstein
cackling cackling giggling
he didn't know what he was in for
because he's like a really religious
Rabbi and I was like we want to do vows
he's like well he's like yeah we want to
say something to each other he's like
okay yeah and I don't think he was
prepared for the comedy the emotion the
realness it was very raw but also
hysterical he said it's raw he said rip
this is wrong
he did say that I heard it I heard it
too
damn well I don't know how he got here
but I'm deeply sad about yeah nothing
and I I now want to like go back and
watch some of her stuff but I'm sure
we'll see a lot of tributes which is
always kind of a nice way to remember
someone yeah especially someone who was
like taken too soon yes and such an icon
are you ready for our next story yes
I'm not no clearly I'm ready it's just I
have to do things on my phone today long
long story
things on your phone yesterday when I'm
in New York I have to do it what are you
gonna bring your iPad here for eam the
man involved in the shooting of Lady
Gaga's dog walker has been sentenced to
21 years in prison one of the people
charged in the shooting and robbery of
Lady Gaga's dog walker last year has
been sentenced to 21 years in state
prison the LA County District's Attorney
office said on Monday James Howard
Jackson pleaded no contest to one count
of attempted murder and admitted the
allegation of conflicting great bodily
injury and to a prior strike as part of
the settlement the DA's office said in a
statement oh he had a prior the dog
walker Ryan Fisher was walking Lady
Gaga's Three French Bulldogs on February
24th 2021 when he was accosted and shot
the attackers fled and stole two of the
dogs Koji and Gustav two of the men
jumped out of the car and began to choke
and hit Fisher who struggled against the
attackers the complaint said one of the
men then shot the dog walker and then
the trio fled with the two dogs the dog
walker was critically injured but
survived the attack and the missing dogs
were later returned into Lady Gaga after
she offered a five hundred thousand
dollar reward for them the plea
agreement holds Mr Jackson accountable
for perpetrating a cold-hearted violent
act and provides Justice for our victim
you know this is oh and remember that he
was released the Kirk was accidentally
released from custody in April due to
what officials called a clerical error
moronic but was found in August and
taken back into custody good
so and now he has
um his 21-year sentence in prison you
know what I remember when we reported on
this it was such an upsetting story like
so so disgusting
um and so I'm you'd love to see the
justice system doing its thing finally
um but you know my new thing is like
really measuring people's
um sentences against the Chrisley one I
know that sounds crazy and I know it's
different states and it's different laws
once Federal I get it but it's like 21
years and you literally tried to murder
someone
and he gets half the time for like
stealing some money from a bank you know
yeah and I'm not saying that to like
invalidate what he did because it is a
crime but it's just interesting when you
like compare people's sentences because
honestly the sentencing in this country
like kind of makes no sense makes no
sense I compare things to the sentencing
for hate crimes and anti-semiticisms in
New York well in New York they just let
them go yeah and they do it again and
again and again you know that's like
because it is different in every state
and like the laws are different
um so I think this is a fabulous really
fabulous sentence and I'm I'm glad that
this chapter ended but it's so
interesting when you just compare
people's sentences you know right and
also I feel like there was so much
outpouring of support when this happened
which was really amazing but it felt
like there was so much um almost more
care for these dogs than the John Walker
remember she like offered the reward for
the dogs but like what about the human
in the hospital yeah and I have to
assume that Lady Gaga like um covered
all the expenses for him and they never
released that because she's not like
tacky like that but I have to assume
that like her and I I I'm gonna choose
to believe that like there actually very
close and she was very upset and she
paid for all that maybe she even
recovered in a house that she rented for
him by the beach you know yeah I mean
I'm gonna assume that honestly I am
because Lady Gaga seems cool like that
yeah
yeah like a lady I'm not I don't have
public perception yeah just like even
you know you hear their stories of like
crime stories robberies even murders in
L.A and like where the perpetrators yeah
but like this one there was dogs
involved and everyone's like no it's
true but it was also because it was Lady
Gaga yeah and also like we need to
protect the dogs too we absolutely have
to which it was just a really [ __ ]
upsetting story when it happened because
this is first of all a human being and
then to take your violence out on
animals is another level yeah
another level that was this has been
like a crazy Saga where they let him out
I'm like how [ __ ] dumb can you be
yeah you literally have one job yeah
when it comes to like an inmate it's
like keep them in yeah it's not an
outmate it's an amazing Justice being
served yes there are very few no and you
try and kill someone like
whether you're successful or not your
intention was still to kill a person yes
so you should honestly I don't think
your sentence should be less because you
didn't succeed right sorry you're dumb
yes you're bad
bye bye enjoy prison
are you ready for our next story is it
the next story that's brought you by
manscaped per chance yeah I think it is
oh here they want me to sing so the
brand requested it I have to Santa Baby
it must be a holiday Miracle because the
sponsor of today's show manscaped are
stuffing your stockings with everything
that the man in your life could ask for
that right that
that right that's right this holiday
season manscaped has vowed to make sure
that his ornaments are shining bright
and his tree is Standing Tall spice up
never disappoints no not with the spicy
sounds like one of my books
spice up his stocking with gifts he'll
actually use and something you can enjoy
too if you don't believe in Santa you
better believe in this they've changed
the lives of six seven excuse me million
men and you can get 20 off I'm like
having trouble talking today you can get
20 off and free shipping by going to
manscaped.com toast this is the best
gift for the man in your life and for
you and for you like it's for you it's
for you it's one of those gifts yes to
them and it's for you they have
everything at manscaped the performance
package 4.0 really comes with everything
that you can need you know who I think
uses manscaped allegedly rip I by the
way manscapes literally needs to make
rip the face of their company because
like the leather it has the beard and
yeah it's like and it's gorgeous it's
like wild but it's also kemped you're so
wrong because he's manscaping so the
performance package 4.0 has everything
inside that you could possibly need the
lawnmower body trimmer the weed whacker
which is for ear and nose hair trimmings
um their famous liquid formulations like
the crop preserver which is a ball
deodorant the crop reviver which is a
ball toner it's gonna smell nice it's
gonna feel nice it's going to look great
and it's time like you take care of
yourself like it's time for your man to
start taking care of himself so save 20
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com toast that's 20 off in free
shipping by going to manscaped.com toast
cheers to rocking the best gifts of all
this season a gift for him but really a
gift for you I'm a gift for it and you
know what I do give a rip that's the
craziest thing that's happened yes plot
twist plot twist I'll give a rip are we
even speaking English today like I don't
think so but I think that the people who
are here with us are you following I
think they're found unless this is your
first day as a toaster and I'm so sorry
Watch yesterday's episode yeah this is a
very in the know episode it is and I'm I
don't know what to say and I'm having a
great time I don't know the cause of it
is delirium
that's the cause delirium and the Cure
listened to yesterday's episode I don't
remember that are you ready for our next
story which is some exciting Revival
recap reboot SQL news
it's somewhat sequel news oh okay
Cameron Diaz signs up for the holiday
sequel with the original cast Reviving
their roles after the retired star
announced her surprising return to
acting now 16 years later it's been
reported that the holiday is set for a
sequel with stars Cameron Diaz Jude Law
Kate Winslet and Jack Black iconic all
on board now let me ask you a question
who would you think is the oldest of
those four people
that's a really good question let me
think who look who look oldest 20 years
ago when the movie came out Cameron Diaz
Jude Law Kate Winslet Jack Black I'm
gonna say Kate Winslet is the youngest
oh what she's younger than Cameron Diaz
okay and who's the oldest Jack Black oh
that was gonna be my second guess and
let me give you the ages Cameron Diaz is
50. Iconic law is 49. still hot Kate
Winslet is 47. ethereal and Jack Black
is 53. Legend but the legend of the rent
was way past due
yeah
the original get off your ass let's do
some math math math math math math math
the original movie written and directed
by Nancy Myers twin tale of the Surrey
based journalist Iris certain County
Missouri Surry County
Sherry County where uh ladama's from
no Surrey no I know I know sorry it was
like a funny joke oh my God
you're crossing your wires I'm getting
my wires crossed
because you were crossing them because
the wires were crossed
okay they swap homes you know love and
heartbreak follows
um so actually there's been like so many
heartbreak then love I feel like over
the like the last 20 years since the
movie came out and like the fandom of
the movie is like grown and grown there
have been so many different like
conversations being had it's like what
actually happens in the end like do they
all does Kate Winslet really stay in L.A
like where does everyone end up like we
know they end up together but like
physically geographically where do they
move and actually I was just watching a
tick tock of someone who's like I
figured it out because Jude Law
obviously has to stay in London and
Cameron Diaz can work remote so she
probably went to London
and then Jack Black and K Winslet
probably do like transatlantic travel
like what was her job
he scored movies right or she scored
movies who scored movies
he did he did he scored movies and she
she worked at the newspaper but then she
threw that for like she definitely
doesn't work there anymore for that when
she had mail went yeah I don't know if
they ended up like quitting or whatever
but she definitely doesn't work there
anymore she probably got a job at like
the LA Times great so they've canceling
people for a living they could be in La
yeah right but then it's like don't the
four of them like want to be together
and like no they don't [ __ ] know each
other well he's a brother and those are
her her nieces so that's why that's why
the tick tocker had thought that like
Jack Black and Kate Winslet probably do
like half the year in LA and half the
year in London that's cute yeah but so
you think everyone's still together
for sure I think
if there was no sequel I would say
everyone's still together but I think
they're gonna have to like make
something happen and I think it's gonna
be
Cameron Diaz and Jude Law like I think
that Kate Winslet and Jack Black were
more stable I agree but he has a kid who
Jude lost so it's like you can't really
like
you're more serious with who you settle
down with because you're bringing them
in front of your kids for sure but like
it's still a 10-year relationship is
still successful okay but are they gonna
get back together at the end of the
sequel I don't know I kind of like hate
a sequel for me that's so perfect right
unless like you keep everyone together
in happy relationships and there's just
like a different variant coming in and
maybe it's Omicron
Delta but maybe it's something like
someone else are switching houses right
the maybe their neighbor or something
and they're just kind of like adjacent
to it yeah I like that but honestly I I
don't know if this is a hot take but
like I'm not really here for this or
they like Cameron Diaz moved to Surrey
Kate Winslet moved to LA and now they're
switching houses their families are
switching houses
for this holiday that's good or
you lost kid is probably like 20 now
maybe the kid is holiday like maybe she
and her but then like why is Cameron
Diaz signing on to be like a ancillary
character no totally she's retired from
acting she doesn't get out of bed for
just nothing I think they're stable
families are switching again that's
actually really cute
and maybe she falls in love and Nancy
Myers is involved yes I think so yeah I
mean she has to be yeah there's yeah
honestly nothing will really ruin like
the sanctity and like the the
um Legacy of a film more than a reboot
even a good one like it just something
about not having a reboot these days
like makes you cooler like you live in
like but there's no reason why it has to
be bad you know what I mean like why
can't Nancy Myers sit down to write a
movie about she has like four leading no
that's true and there's just gonna be a
little bit of holiday in between Nancy
Myers really um like she doesn't just
put out a movie for the sake of putting
out a movie even if it feels like a
movie
I have to assume like if she's on board
like it will be a stunning project just
like a beautiful movie like a classic of
Nancy Myers I'm even going to Nancy
Meyer since the intern oh no home again
that one's sung yeah Reese Witherspoon
like being a pedophile yeah
like not my fave not my favorite concept
from Nancy but you know Everyone's
entitled to an off-year you know she was
in her flop era yeah yeah
but anyways I think this is exciting
news I don't think Cameron Diaz would
sign on for anything less than Stellar I
think all of these people actually have
a really high bar Jack Black doesn't
even work that much unless it's some
Kung Fu Panda so I think this is going
to be great and I think this is what we
need we need greatness no and we need
like wholesome delicious content like
Jack Black is really America's
sweetheart and so is Cameron Diaz and so
is Kate Winston the other two are you UK
sweethearts so we need a swap totally
yeah so this just feels like exactly
what we as a society need right now I
agree and this agrees that movie is
perfect I love the holiday and you know
what's so funny I actually haven't seen
it in full up until a few years ago yeah
you weren't ready I wasn't reading your
time it's so good did you watch it again
so true it's one I would say it's the
best holiday movie
I'd have to sit and think on that
should we go yeah like Love Actually is
up there I probably haven't seen all of
like the top ones that people regard but
like the Family Stone was great but I
still think the holiday is the best one
you name me one and I'll tell you if any
of them are better okay
top holiday movies
Miracle on 34th Street I'm sure it's
great but no uh Four Christmases I
actually just tuned that on the other
day
Vince Vaughn and Reese Witherspoon okay
you know what else we know what's up
there though like elf that's probably
one of the best Christmas movies yes yes
yes it's a wonderful life Polar Express
the Grinch the Grinch is up there as
well the Grinch might out of everything
I've read so far might be my number one
but you know Home Alone of course and
the second one you know what about the
Grinch I feel like Hollywood like thinks
that they're due for a grinch update
that's like one of those movies like
Beauty and the Beast they do it again
and Jim Carrey's version for me that
will always be the Grinch yeah but I
feel like for our kids it won't be I
feel like there'll be a new one soon
there was a new one just recently that
was animated but it got like the whole
The Works they have the Kylie collab
like oh no no still like I need like a
real life I feel like I'm gonna redo it
with Matthew like they did the Matthew
Morrison one but I thought that's what
you were gonna write I think the Grinch
is like on Hiatus for a second so which
is good I think it should be I think
like in perpetuity the Jim Carrey one
should be the one and if they want to
redo it it has to be with Jim Carrey
yeah
oh um like the there's bad Santa and
then there's also the other Santas like
uh Fred Claus I love that movie those
ones what do they call him like yeah
there's like three of them yeah whatever
with Tim Allen yeah what the [ __ ] are
those movies called Tim Allen Christmas
hold on let me think it's like Mr Claus
or something and then they did Fred the
brother Vince Vaughn
the Santa Claus and the Santa Clauses oh
they could have done better with the
name yeah
um but I stand by what I said I think
the holiday is probably the greatest
holiday movie of all time for me my
number one is the Grinch it's just a
different vibe You're a mean one you
really are a Mr shrice you really are a
crunch
you're as mean as dancing
that's a good like kids movie writers a
little scary no it's fun okay great
lesson and iconic Jenny from Gossip
Girls in it yep also that new one is now
probably a good Christmas movie for kids
yeah the oh spirited yeah
so I'm happy about this reboot I'll see
it remains to be seen But if Nancy Myers
is on I trust her implicitly mm-hmm
are you ready for our next story a
little more movie news yeah Margot
Robbie improvised a scene for the
opportunity to kiss Brad Pitt in her new
movie love that for her Margot Robbie
admits that she persuaded Babylon
director Damien chazelle I hope they got
Babel as a sponsor to get her characters
to kiss in their movie of course I mean
if you're going to be like in a movie
with Brad Pitt and not kiss him what are
you doing what are you doing she said
that wasn't in the script uh but I
thought when else am I going to get the
chance to kiss Brad Pitt I'm just gonna
go for it she convinced the director to
let her lock lips with Brad arguing that
she thought it was what the characters
were doing
she said quote not her gaslighting
everyone on set like no it's what the
character requires like if a man did
this of course no but because Margot
Robbie did it Stan Queen yeah she said
Damien I think Nelly would just go up
and kiss Jack and Damian was like well
she could wait hold on you just want to
kiss Brad Pitt and I was like oh so sue
me this opportunity might never come up
again and he was like it does work for
the character and I was like I think so
let me tell you how much I appreciate
Margot Robbie like acknowledging the
fact that like even if you're an actor
and you're kissing someone like a kiss
is a kiss I hate when actors like
Gaslight us and to be like it's just the
work no like it is the work but you are
kissing another human being and I love
that Margot Robbie is like married and
was like using this as an excuse we like
let me just kiss Brad Pitt you know it's
like what really is a once in a lifetime
opportunity and I love that she
recognized that yes she also said she
was satisfied when she did get to kiss
him but she also was pleasantly
surprised when the director realized
that the intimate moment between the
characters really did work for the scene
right so she's serving herself but then
out here serving the whole film you know
not even on purpose it's a win for
everyone and he was like do it again
that really works that is so beautiful
Margot Robbie she's literally just one
of us just one of us I also love that
she's married and she's not only like
was this her internal monologue but
she's telling everyone like it's just
funny and it's funny and relatable I'm
sure her and her husband are fighting
about it at home right now because it's
like but don't you think the fact that
like she would go on and tell the story
like means that like they have a healthy
like work that's something
it's like you to a point but then
because I'm also like how could someone
like not be upset about that unless like
he's Brad Pitt is like her whole past no
see that's what I really don't like when
when celebrities actors talk about this
part of their work they totally diminish
it and like they don't even acknowledge
like it is weird like even though it's
fake you're still in real life touching
someone else's lips with your own so
like there has to be an element of
weirdness and I wish people would be
more like open about that like I'm sure
I don't know why this is coming to mind
oh I forgot to tell you I watched a new
Amazon Prime movie with um
what the [ __ ] is her name Kristen Bell
is that her name Gossip Girl yeah
Ben Platt Princess Anna Allison Janny
haven't heard the people we hate at the
wedding uh I think I saw the title um
isn't that the same thing as table nine
table 19. no it was a different concept
it was kind of cute and funny Ben hated
it and like it was dumb at some points
and like honestly this pains me to say
because like I actually left him but
like Ben Platt was probably the worst
part of the film and he was not right
for it
um however
it was a cute film where am I going with
this oh because you know she's always
like you know everyone knows her and Dax
Shepard like love love love and in this
movie she's like making out a lot like
[ __ ] in closets and I just couldn't
like you can't tell me that like even in
the slightest it doesn't like bother to
act Shepherd like of course you're used
to it but like if you were to really ask
him to his core
it's a human
I think for them it probably works
because they're both actors but like if
you're if only one person is like
getting to Rendezvous also if it were me
I mean it wouldn't be me but if it were
I wouldn't launch it
but it's like the fact that I can't
watch it means it's because there's
something wrong with it right so if it
was me in bed was an actor like kissing
other women oh my God first of all I'd
literally [ __ ] kill myself
um but
I'm the type of person like I know I
shouldn't watch it but I would just to
make myself sick because I like to self
like I like to hurt myself yeah no I I'm
the type of person if I don't see it it
doesn't exist no that's that's really
smart but then it's like everyone was
talking about it I know it's in the
Press they're talking about it so you
turn a blind eye like maybe I would have
seen that there was chemistry between
them right years later you wish you had
seen it
yeah as I said it couldn't be me
couldn't wouldn't should not should not
right Bryce what would you do if you saw
Magnolia kissing another
you say [ __ ] that [ __ ] she's a [ __ ]
that's what he would say
Bryce is a foul mouth it wasn't my words
it was his he does have a foul mouth
he's disgusting anyway he's like a
sailor Margot Robbie is out on her press
tour being a relatable Queen and what's
this film it's obviously Oscar Babylon
sponsored by Babel no like what's the
concept oh let me Google Babylon film
concept I feel like
are the Oscars coming up
like I feel like we're like three months
away this is when Margot Robbie Brad
Pitt is like an Oscar Vibe yes of course
follows a young Mexican man in the 1920s
who has aspirations of working in
Hollywood but when he falls in love with
a crazed Rising Star his life becomes
one giant Whirlwind oh that sounds good
Babylon will be Paramount's big Oscar
entry in 2022. yeah no Margot Robbie and
Brad Pitt it's like recipe for Success
yeah can't wait to see it can't wait to
see it speaking of what everyone's
seeing a new study has come out and it
will be our fifth and final story
parks Associates has just put out a new
study about the top streaming services
that consumers are using I was really
shocked by what the number one was
um because if I hadn't seen it and I
would have had to guess what the number
one streaming service is I might say
like
honestly like just Netflix like because
it's so Global I would say Netflix and
Netflix has been number one for the last
three years okay so this year this year
the number one streaming service is
TNN plus no it's a Prime video makes you
think it does and I was really shocked
but then you made a really good point
like I feel like people like use Amazon
so much like for shopping they probably
have Prime and don't even know it like
honestly I cannot tell you when the [ __ ]
I signed up for Prime video but I have
it same I don't even remember when I
signed up for Amazon Prime like it was
in college because my Amazon account is
like literally linked up to my like high
school email account same not only do I
think a lot of people are Prime video
members without realizing or Amazon like
gives it to them for free and it's
always running specials but I think you
know people don't like to put their
information into a lot of different
systems and so everyone uses Amazon
Amazon has you're naming your credit
card and it's like oh and I wanted to
watch that show I like charge it right
and I know a lot of people use Amazon
you can subscribe to other streaming
platforms through Amazon that's really
smart so it does make sense the more I
thought about it but I was really
shocked that it that it was prime it
felt so Random because also Prime hasn't
had like a cult show like go viral in a
really long time like I feel like all
the shows that are so popular like Hulu
has a lot of shows that go viral and
they got nominated for like Oscars and I
mean Golden Globes obviously like
Wednesday right now on Netflix is
popping off Bridgerton like they have
like a million things that go crazy
viral and I'm like what does Amazon even
make Samurai turn pretty yes that would
like probably compete with Bridgerton
they had that new Chris Pratt show I
Don't Know Jack something oh the
terminal yeah
um people love oh okay
there's more I mean when they did not
make a season three of that Country Club
show Red Oaks that's when they lost me
like that was the best show not to give
you something to watch though like will
make you sick because there's not a
third season it was so good Red Oaks
yeah and they also just have a lot of
other content like that they've snatched
up right and I guess now that I think
about it me and Ben are like stay in and
watch a movie and like we're gonna buy
like a run to film I'll do it on Amazon
yeah and even though I have Apple TV I
don't really like to buy on the iTunes
Store I don't know why I think I buy an
iTunes I know because I think like I'll
find something on iTunes that'll be like
maybe it's free on Prime and then I'll
go to Prime and it's not free but I'm
already there you know yeah
actually you have to put like a five
digit code it's really [ __ ] annoying
yeah but that's easier than remembering
my password yeah yeah because if the
code's been for me it will find me but
the new thing on Apple TV is like when I
want to buy something I could just click
a button on my phone like they're like
you can put in your password or confirm
on your phone then I get this little
notification I just press yes
interesting yeah they're really
innovating over at
I also feel like your streaming habits
really depend on what interface you use
like I use an Apple TV but for a while I
used a fire stick and then I did
everything through Amazon just because
they obviously make it the easiest to do
that so
by that logic I feel like Apple TV would
be bigger was Apple TV even on the list
of like top 10 because their streaming
services are not relevant yeah their
shooting service is really stupid it's
stupid bad and embarrassing and if it
weren't for Ted lasso no one no one I
have to I have Apple TV for one month a
year and then I move on yeah no like
every once in a while there's something
there was like they had my mind in me so
I popped on but it's worthless no and it
should be a lot better because I would
argue like most young people gravitate
towards Apple TV over like a Roku or
anything yeah I have an Apple TV but you
couldn't catch me on Apple TV plus no
they're always trying like they're
always sliding me up to the top Apple TV
plus [ __ ] off yeah okay so number two is
Netflix okay which you know is expected
considering it was won the last few
years but like will this trend downwards
continue I don't know who knows they
spend a lot of money and they also had
like they had a few really great years
because of covid but now one everybody's
beefing up their competition and two
like people are like turning on Netflix
like they're just like done with it no
because like it it's been around for so
long and it's been like the go-to and I
feel like like when I go to Netflix I
know I'm not going to find something you
know what I mean yes but it's like I
still pay for scrolling yeah yeah number
three is Hulu
Hulu kills it yeah their interface still
sucks yeah but their content in the
middle of an episode they'll throw you
back to the beginning it's like no why
would I want to watch this again
the interface is unwell but they have
like a lot like Pam and Tommy was great
they have a lot of really good original
content the
tell me lies tell me lies Kardashians
they have good [ __ ] yep and they do
great with live TV like people now I
know a lot of people excuse me one two
three
Plus gazunt
a lot of people like rely on Hulu to
watch like the next morning
um like dancing with the Disney stars
but like ABC they have live sports now
they kill it in live TV then number four
is Disney plus makes sense
it's a solid streamer not for me within
the Disney Family yeah yeah number five
HBO Max I started um I'm all caught up
on the new season of uh
sex lives with college girls it's it's
so good I'm so excited I'm gonna wait
till it's done I know it was really
frustrating I watched the first maybe
four or five so it wasn't terrible it's
really it's a stellar show like it's
it's a perfect show and Pauline chalamet
is the queen like the way I'm obsessed
with her when I feel like she would have
been the character I hated is the show
suffering because the brother is not
there anymore no I completely forgotten
there's like a new Hawkeye who moved in
next door who's like into Kimberly and
like it's everything can't wait yeah six
ESPN plus what by the way you know
what's embarrassing is that Apple TV
plus is below ESPN plus like that's
crazy yeah but here's what's crazy then
seven is Paramount plus eight is Apple
TV and nine is peacock so like Paramount
plus is bigger than peacock that makes
sense really Paramount plus like is kind
of everything what do you watch there
RuPaul's Drag Race
yellow I watch her on peacock
it's Paramount Joe no I know but I'm
telling you I literally just had to pay
9.99 because I was not watching
commercials I think the first time I
watched it I watched it on peacock 2
maybe they host it no it's not I'm
Paramount but I'm telling them literal
Network like I watch it on cable TV on
cable yeah no that's a really good call
um I feel like Paramount plus actually
is in a pretty good spot for being the
newest one on that list
um and they do kind of they kill it they
have the Jersey Shore
um they have a lot of stuff number 10 is
Stars
what
like I've never even like I know stars
that has a network I don't even know
they had a streaming service and they're
one spot below Apple TV plus I feel like
the point of this
discussion as a as a story was not Apple
TV but now like it's like it's it's
actually like embarrassing yeah like
where's Discovery plus next year they'll
be bigger because of the Culpo sisters
trust me that show is changing hearts
and Minds it's doing things it's doing
things too and I'm a few episodes behind
I see some of the headlines and I like
need to go and watch I saw a headline
too they obviously like you know it's so
funny how the media can really make you
like think people are annoying and
stupid and then like you really need to
look at it through a lens because it was
like Olivia's sister Sophia resents
Olivia's Fame like it was just like it
was such a dumb headline and I'm like I
was about to be like eye roll and then
I'm I was thinking to myself she
probably didn't say that like that's
probably not what she said no and I'm
sure that was part of a much larger
conversation because they have um
there's been there's some tension I
think it comes to came to a head in the
recent episode between me and Olivia
yeah because there's been like clothes
stealing and Sophia lives with Olivia
and she's not a very good house guest
and
um I think also like Olivia like Sophia
does a lot of similar work that Olivia
does like she's a model and she's the
one sister and think like Olivia like
looks at her and like kind of wants to
correct her like because yeah you know
she went through it and so there's just
like sisterlyting sisterly Tings but
they're also like love each other so
much and that's a small part yeah so
it's really good stuff you guys should
be watching
um so I want to tell you about the
episodes of yell so that I watched last
night and it's brought to you by the
perfect bar don't go nuts this holiday
season is what I need right now fuel
yourself with the perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar made
with freshly ground nut butter organic
honey and 20 organic superfoods perfect
bar has a variety of products like
protein bars and snack size bars that
are all so good and good for you you are
sure to find something you love my
favorite is the dark chocolate chip
peanut butter with sea salt sea salt is
a stunning addition to like a chocolatey
Savory snack it's delicious and it has
become a go-to snack here at the studio
they have cookie dough texture it's
creamy and full of flavor and perfect
bar knows that it will be Love At First
Bite so I know you're like a an engineer
when it comes to bars yeah tell me about
your experience
bars you love to take the bars Queen
scene Queen at the bars
um I love perfect bar one they make like
a snack size bar which is really the
perfect thing for when you need
something to tide you over and then they
also have bigger bars which can be a
meal replacement depending on where
you're at in your day they're so tasty
they are refrigerated so they taste
fresh and they will keep you full until
you get to where you need to be I love
them and you're right I'm a bar
connoisseur I find other bars too
crunchy sometimes give me a headache
this is a nice texture and consistency
nice flavor I like that they're packed
with nutrients and things that are going
to actually keep you full and not just
you know a candy bar right masquerading
as something healthy because if that's
the case I would rather have candy so
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
if you sign up for email or text upload
a picture of your receipt from your
local grocery store they will reimburse
you for the cost of one bar and it'll go
directly into your venmo or PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free prep perfect bar
today happy snacking today's episode is
also brought to you by Indie Lee a brand
where clean Beauty meets high
performance after surviving a
life-threatening diagnosis the founder
Indie lay set out to follow her true
passion of creating and carefully
curated line of clean products that are
formulated with high performance
plant-derived ingredients that are made
to nurture you and your skin so indeely
products feature award-winning and
clinically proven formulas for maximum
Effectiveness giving you the skin of
your dreams that you can feel good about
the fan favorite is the CoQ10 toner it
sells every four minutes I had never
used a toner I wasn't entirely sure like
what a toner was yes still not sure but
I like how it feels me too the India one
is really good it's Ultra hydrating it's
non-drying and it's alcohol free so it's
a refreshing skin spritzer that is
clinically proven to improve the skin
elasticity the firmness dehydration I
definitely noticed like a brightening
effect on my skin I was like I didn't
know when we were gonna have this hat
but I got the Indie Lee stuff a while
ago and I'm so obsessed I brought it
with me
um to New York like it's in my travel
case and it like it has all of the
different things that you need like it's
this whole skincare system like each
product is good and it's clean and like
your skin is happy so they have a ton of
best-selling products like the three in
one brightening cleanser the Spritz
hydrating toner that we just spoke about
if you want to use code toast at
checkout you can get 20 off your first
purchase and it's indeedlee.com
i-n-d-i-e-l-e-e.com slash code toast
excuse me indylee.com 20 off for code
toast clean Beauty meets high
performance that cleanser is amazing so
uh okay Yellowstone last night I
finished episode season two and I
watched the first episode of season
three now the end of season two is when
Tate gets abducted
and he gets abducted by like Nazi
skinheads and like it was really
upsetting like me but that episode was
so tense because they made it seem like
rip was gonna die and I don't know if
it's because you and Margo like I I mean
men are convinced everything I'm
convinced that ripped eyes and so what
happens is like they're going on this
Mission and they know it's gonna be
really dangerous and so before he does
John Dutton like finally acknowledges
rip as his son and gives him that house
on the hill so I'm like oh man they're
gonna do all this because and then he's
gonna die because that's what TV does
they play with you
and then you know Casey it's Casey's kid
but like Casey won't be the first one to
go in on Horseback when they're like go
to the mountains or whatever
rip is and rip they know it's a it's a
risk why won't Casey be the first one
because John won't let him like he's the
heir currently so like he doesn't
take that risk got it so me and Ben are
just like literally we're already crying
like I literally have tears in my eyes I
know he's gonna die then he doesn't and
they get the kid back and it's all good
so it was like so much drama for what
you know entertainment value but what I
did find really interesting was like
once they finally got the kid back it
was my assumption that Monica would be
like all right they took our kid like
I'm [ __ ] out of here but if anything
like her resolution is now like stronger
on the other way she's like I understand
now what it's like this is what it was
like for my people when we lived on this
land like everyone was coming at us
stealing our children raping our women
to get this land like there was nothing
they wouldn't do and that's what you're
going through now she's like the
difference is like you're the Indians
now so I was not expecting that sort of
reaction from her I don't know if that's
gonna stay but like for now she seems
happy to be living at the ranch in the
master suite and then also I mean I
barely remember the storyline but then
she also just like feel like these
people would do anything for her and her
family well she hasn't said that yet but
I'm assuming she's very grateful because
like they literally they're all obsessed
with Tate especially John I mean when
they were in this war with the Beck
Brothers and like John let the kid go
outside by himself at night to feed the
horse and obviously that's when he gets
abducted like I'm sorry how dumb are you
also when the [ __ ] are they gonna get
like a gate or like I don't know a
security guard at the the front like
anyone just rolls up to this house sure
but they could have someone at the front
and I'm sure that they do have a gate
but no they show you the gate it's
literally like an arch and just drive
through it but they have
acres and acres of land anyone could
just roll through roll through yeah
that's true okay we'll come through the
back no I really thought that like
because it was all high stakes with this
Tate thing and it's like you know
everyone's like we're gonna lose the
ranch but we don't care we just have to
get tape like
I thought it was like finally the moment
for rip and Beth and it's like what is
the plan here like they're obviously OTP
but then there's a new neighbor moves in
and it's Sawyer from Lost I love that
actor he's so hot okay he's like fishing
in the river and he would like asked her
out on a date and she said no but
there's obviously something that's going
to happen there but it's like what the
[ __ ]
no comment no and I I love that actor
like I'm kind of like here for him and
Beth but like rip is OTP but that could
be like what just what he needs the kick
in the pan but I feel like it's not up
to rip it's up to Beth yeah so season
one happened episode one season three
now what's going on oh the the okay so
Dan Jenkins is dead and he's like who
the [ __ ] owns the land that he had
purchased he like annexed it to the
reservation but then it was owned by
Paradise Valley whatever so all these
suits are coming around and there's like
this new evil guy who's in charge of
like this big group of investors who
technically own the land now
Dan's land yeah okay like next to
the ranch yeah and Beth and her crew I
love her boss I hope he doesn't turn
everyone
oh my God that's who it is
um I love that like he's helping her but
she's also helping him like they're
making a lot of money yeah um I love him
yeah I love love love love love that's
he's a great actor in general oh he's
always like he's a Victor Garber so
season one episode of Television yes
he's a Victor Harbor Greg he's a Victor
Garber of TV season three episode one
was this iconic scene that has actually
gone viral on Tick Tock so many times
I've seen it
when that [ __ ] and I honestly never
use this word [ __ ]
of a boutique owner accuses Monica of
stealing and she calls Beth and Beth
when Beth oh my God that's the I had
seen that scene before I didn't know the
context but that clip has gone viral on
Tick Tock like many times really and
Monica was like stop like you're
embarrassing her like it's enough like
you know it's not gonna make what she
did to me any better and Beth leaves the
store and she's like I was gonna make
you [ __ ] that mannequin iconic iconic I
[ __ ] love Beth
um and that's a great friendship um like
that you likely didn't know you were
waiting for wait because they're like
sisters and I have a call I want to put
out there so Jamie that [ __ ]
um didn't you say he was your favorite
like a few okay I had seen one episode I
didn't say he was my favorite hold on I
need to find Claudia's text from when
she first started watching out soon we
were FaceTiming no oh we were yeah but
didn't I tell you to screen record
yourself yeah but I told you screen
recording and FaceTime doesn't pick up
the audio and then you mean like I was
wondering about three episodes in and I
said Jamie's like a good son he was a
good son he was a great lawyer okay so
continue
he killed the journalist because he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then he's finally
being let back in the good graces very
slowly you know John gave up his seat as
livestock commissioner
um
for killing the back brothers and he
wanted the job to go to Casey Casey
obviously won't take it she for friends
and so Beth was like actually give it to
Jamie because you know in order to do
that job you need people to like you and
who's more obsessed with getting people
to like them than Jamie he'll actually
be good and she was right John agreed so
he's like kind of like getting his way
back into the fold but he just found out
that but she's pregnant so the girl he
was shacking up with but let me tell you
how I don't think she's pregnant I
actually think it was a really smart
thing of her because like she knows so
much now about the family and like she
sees that the family will just kill
anyone who like poses a threat but if
she's pregnant with his child she buys
herself nine months I don't think she's
pregnant but um it's hella inconvenient
if she is so it's just my call I just
want to say I've been avoiding spoilers
like mad like if you're watching on
YouTube please don't comment any
spoilers like I know that's a law firm
but I'd love to read the YouTube
comments like people like tell me how
funny and beautiful I am so I don't want
to have to not do that until I finish
you know what I mean okay
but like move swiftly I know make haste
I know I will be done by next Monday I
promise I'm gonna spend the whole
weekend doing it so and it's really not
that many episodes it's 10 episodes and
I'm on season three and what are we on
season five episode three now yeah I
guess so it's only like 20 more episodes
It's like a whole day three is really
great okay I'm excited yeah and then
season four is great but like it's the
greatness starts it's so beautiful like
these houses it really like oh and do
you want to issue a correction about
something from yesterday
what the horses yes but I want to ask
you a correction you are so I never said
no but like you you accused no I didn't
because it always makes me sad to see it
doesn't make you sad it should make you
feel joyous it does that these horses
are employed and I got so many messages
from people who alerted me to the fact
that Tyler Sheridan the creator of the
show most of the cattle and the horses
that are featured in the show belong to
him so he's of course overseeing that
they're taken care of with the greatest
of
care and it made me feel great and I did
I just said I don't assume that if
there's like horses somewhere that
they're being mistreated but there's
plenty of horse files more so than you
who would take a bullet for those horses
I never said that I think anything's bad
going on should I put out there like
you're just like assuming things you're
accusing and just zooming
I can't talk to it again like this like
Pharrell I can't hmm because you're
wrong
say I just like
like
it was your go-to feeling I'm too
exhausted honestly I don't I don't have
the energy to go Tit for Tat with you on
this because you could go forever no no
no
no
no
no
so excited to be on this journey thank
you for everyone for being as excited as
me again I'm sorry that it took me so
long I'm stubborn you're right I'm wrong
I'm dumb you're smart and there's
nothing you can do about it okay sure
you're Danny DeVito and I'm Matilda
sure so that's our show anything you
want to catch up on before we wrap up
no I feel perfectly caught up tomorrow's
episode is going to be really special
really fun Claudia won't be with me but
I'm recording with someone else Audio
Only so if you're watching on YouTube if
you're a YouTuber head to the audio
tomorrow it's worth should we transition
should we like tell who it is
I don't know we never do nah nah nah nah
you'll see you tomorrow yeah
so that's our show you guys thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found at Spotify iTunes
teacher public radio I already castbox
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us leave it toast and
we'll leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning wickedly talented we
are hope you guys have an incredib
Tuesday I will see you on Thursday
Jackie will see you tomorrow love ya
I'll hear you tomorrow love ya bye